[Music]
all right so we've been in this pandemic
for a good what five
and a half 15 days full life it feels
like 15 days to slow the spread like how
many months
this year has probably been the slowest
year
of my life it feels fast it's already
october
yeah it was pretty fast it feels like
it's not september girl
don't speed it up you know what
by the time this video comes out oh it's
december but
yeah so and then so how are your
feelings
um have they changed at all about
wearing a mask
now that we like the longer we get
because you know a lot of people are
just like exhausted they're they're
opening up a little bit more about going
out into the world not
so so much in inside of their home so i
wonder if you guys have changed your
ideas
or like your views on wearing them my
views on the masks
is an emotional view so it hasn't
changed which is
we're a team we're in this together i
don't really know what the [ __ ] facts
and science and biology is
but if we haven't beat it let's all wear
it so my views haven't changed i've been
doing it since
like a kid so it's not oh right but not
in america though because like in
america if i wore the i was like oh
that's lame like
it looks so weird yeah and then you get
kind of judged because
no one wore masks here but in japan if
you have
like a runny nose or you're just
coughing or whatever um
they'll look at you like where the [ __ ]
is your mask yeah you brewed before yeah
so then when i'm out there my mom always
like
oh you gotta run your nose here put this
on and then i have to put it on so i
just got used to
wearing a mask um and then i can adjust
in both cultures so when we had it it
wasn't like a big deal to me
i was just like okay let me just put it
on what's cool about the thugs in asia
is you can always tell because when they
wear their mouths they kind of sag it a
little bit oh that's tiny and then they
have a little nose
yeah that's weird and they still smoke
their cigarettes by putting the max
under on their chin and they smoke like
this yeah
how about you steve i feel i feel the
same way i just feel like uh
it makes people feel good to see you in
a mask so i wear it for that reason i
don't leave my house so like
i just you don't wear it in your house
just so you could feel like you belong
from the outside her window i have like
really cute ones from etsy so when i do
get to wear it it's like oh i got my
accessory
you know you don't go to the supermarket
nah he doesn't i order my groceries
i actually like wearing a mask on the
plane though oh yeah
i didn't realize like i would always get
like a dry ass mouth that's the only
time that i ever wore a mask before the
pandemic i would always wear one on the
plane and now i'm like oh okay now it's
not just on the plane now i get to wear
it everywhere i go
my compliments to masks by the way i
have not smelled a fart in like six
months
oh yeah think of the last time you
smelled the fork fart smoke got in there
and
it's trapped in there yeah and it's like
eating okay
it would have to be my own i haven't
ever worked out with the mask
now i know how bad my breath is wow
thank god now you know god damn
you're just breathing for like two hours
and i'm like damn i don't think my
breath smells that good
i started flossing again you started
flossing again yeah because i heard his
bad breath story
so that same night you're like [ __ ] this
you weren't flossing before maybe like
once a month you probably have so much
plaque there's probably one
i've realized a lot of people don't know
how to floss guys always over exaggerate
the hygiene
am i using the pick or am i using the
string string the string
put it together and then i uh i go up
and down and i push it you're supposed
to go inside
because you know how your teeth it's
like i thought you weren't supposed to
rub it
back and forth but up and down yeah
along the tooth and the gum
like on the edge right you go up and
down up and down yes it's never
up it's like side well i was going like
this i put it up
and then i would go back rocking back
and forth they're like that's not how
you do it
so then uh you go up and down like that
against against the edge along the tooth
yeah
i had to teach him how to do that what
he teaches
like hey you don't see my flossers all
over the goddamn place that's true
it's all over the floor you don't see it
all over the ground couldn't just be
throwing them
just for fun i bought water floss does
that thing work because it works
i haven't used it yet why'd you buy it
what is that that's for people with
braces
that's not true i heard i'm all over
myself i don't have braces to you
to to clean your teeth without having to
do this
motion so i just so it blasts your mouth
with water i guess
it blasts your gum line with water and
it's supposed to like
i actually think you told me so i bought
it on amazon oh was it me
i didn't know that those things existed
yeah well i got one for isaac because he
does have braces and then after
because then like it comes with a lot of
different heads so
i i kept one of the heads so i could try
it and i was like oh [ __ ] this is dope
so i bought one for myself it works
pretty good well there's this one part
of my mouth where there's kind of like a
little hole and food kind of gets stuck
in there
and i need to get fixed but so if food
is stuck in there it won't blast it away
i still need to that's what i was gonna
say is like
so it's good for braces but i feel like
the flossers are more efficient if you
don't have braces
so that's why i have so much plaque i
think food can't get stuck okay well i
got distracted
with the all this oh yeah i still
haven't told you the story so the reason
why i brought up masks is because in
indonesia
they ordered eight people who broke the
country's face mask
laws to dig graves for coven 19 victory
i love indonesia they come up with some
crazy [ __ ]
i actually really like countries that
are hardcore like that they executed
like
eight dudes that were smuggling cocaine
i like it when it's hardcore though
because it like everyone's like oh [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] around you know when you have
that one elementary school like in
singapore they they whip your ass yeah
so
because of the fact that they weren't
wearing masks and they broke the laws
they were like all right [ __ ]
manual labor in the cemetery
yeah but why do they get to wear masks i
mean i thought they're not afraid of
kovid
no they have to wear them and they have
to wear masks they're with coveted
victims
or they know the us reporters were there
and they're like hey we better put these
on real quick
because i'm like in indonesia wearing
all those clothes
it must be very it's hot have you seen
pictures of reporters taking their masks
off and [ __ ] yeah
shit's hilarious wait what's happening
oh just people people
um show reporters on camera with their
masks on and [ __ ] and then
they cut and then the camera they're
taking their masks off with the camera
guy and [ __ ] and like
yeah or they're like oh we're rolling
yeah
hey yeah i've seen that yeah like we
take it very very seriously back to you
and then like
you know what the funniest thing is it's
the restaurant laws that we have oh god
because imagine you go up to the
restaurant and you're like oh [ __ ] you
need a mask to get in so you [ __ ] go
all the way back
they won't even let you in without a
mask no they don't right so you gotta go
back and you get a mask right
and then you go all right i got my mask
cool here
and then you walk two steps and then you
sit down and you [ __ ] take it off
exactly so funny it's so stupid
it's like hey when you're in the hallway
don't forget to have your mask on but
once you sit down at your table you're
fine
like the the aroma is only in the hole
in the table
i mean they say to stay six feet apart
so apparently the rona can't get to you
within six feet that's okay but you're
standing six feet apart in line to get
into the restaurant but you still
but you're wearing a mask to get in and
then once you get seated at the table
there's people passing by all the time
there's no
there's no runner right here but then
what if the person in front of you has
rona right and then so when you move
like this like
the six foot goes forward here you go
and you're in their position so if they
cough here
and it's in that position that's why you
need to wear your mask
that's right as you're waiting now but
because you have your mask on you will
not get it's like protected
no the news reporter one i can
understand if no one's around them like
immediately
oh they're right next to their own
camera guy though that's why they don't
give a [ __ ]
i think they're like we're [ __ ] over
this [ __ ] [ __ ] we just have to do
this for pr reasons but they don't give
a [ __ ]
yeah i'm sure but yeah i don't know my
favorite thing about all this mask
and stuff is just having to see little
kids wear masks because they're all like
smaller are there kid masks yeah yeah
yeah really
has one yeah there's a kid all wearing
little kid mess i'm like oh this is so
cute
doesn't he have a slack one yeah that's
adorable i see people putting it on
their dogs too
on their dogs there's like memes of
people walking outside dogs can't get it
like there was yeah there was reports of
a of a dog that got it
so i don't blame them between that it
looks hilarious but i'm all for that
that's hilarious
i know but yeah so i don't know it's
really interesting because i was looking
on twitter for about this story in
indonesia and a lot of people were
quote tweeting it and saying do this
here cause like a lot of people
don't want to wear masks that's crazy
because in asian countries like i grew
up wearing masks going to taiwan like i
just never thought they would
not wear masks in an asian country
because it's like yeah i thought
everyone just did it out there it seemed
pretty normal
i always hear about these stories but
out where we are i've never seen anyone
not wearing a mask
yeah in la it's pretty serious yeah well
but if you go to oc it's different yeah
i was gonna say in the oc i saw that
i'm just saying with my own eyes i have
not yet seen that but yeah i've seen all
that everywhere in la they have
everyone's wearing masks at our
supermarket i've seen some people
not wear it yeah they look pretty
hardcore though like i'm like
oh that's true i've seen there's some
like super like uh like biker dudes
kind of like kind of like the it took me
a minute the vietnam war
vet or confederate flag like
that group type of people that i don't
give a [ __ ] about anything
america yeah i've seen those and i also
see
younger first it's the mask then it's
all rats
i'm having a barbecue so i'm buying corn
on the cob like those guys
well that's normal thing to buy that's
not a [ __ ] up thing to buy
no but they're standing in line so when
i see them i see them not have a mask
i'm like oh [ __ ] so i just like
sidewinded like okay how did they get in
here
they probably had issues man but i see
those people and i also see like younger
people that look like they're just like
on drugs like they look like they're on
drugs and they they have like a scarf or
whatever but they won't wear it
but i guess like just like shut people
up they kind of just like
in your face it's demonic but they don't
actually wear it i know
freaking crazy i feel bad for like all
the like manual labor workers that like
i see all around the neighborhood you
know gardening and like
it's hot yeah it's hot and they're like
they're out there all day
right yeah yeah workers in norcal
through the fires through pandemic yeah
and then the fires are through the
heat through everything they're still
out there working to get our fruits and
vegetables
tough people but anyway in case you guys
were wondering
indonesia they're reporting that they
have seen infections on the rise with
more than 221 thousand cases
including at least 8 841 deaths
i get it we need [ __ ] like this you know
when we first had our quarantine or it
got shut down in like
march if they had a law like all right
guys you guys have a week or two to get
all your groceries and everything in
order
after that anyone that steps outside of
their house we're going to [ __ ] spank
that's how i thought it was that's what
i was [ __ ] terrified today that's why
they're panicking how do you enforce it
though that's the hard part right
because then you put it up
you need a cop on every street corner
because we're big spread out players
what if you need a band-aid you should
have stocked up on it you should have
got your band-aids already made and
if it's true emergency then you call
9-1-1 and the ambulance will still come
and serve you
do you know how much it costs for an
ambulance did it better be emergency
it's insane that's why you buy your
band-aids now dude you're spend 7g spent
all my money on all this food that
because i've ordered for three months of
food no you spent all your money on
[ __ ] toilet paper
people just that's all that they bought
in the beginning was pandemic it was
just like
they thought it was gonna run out no
they thought they're gonna be [ __ ]
for weeks how much are you gonna ship
bro
that's what blew my mind is like why are
people hoarding toilet paper and paper
towels it's because they're scared
they're scared dude so like beans and
rice is probably what you want i'll wipe
my ass with my own hand
or a sock you would wash
i'll call you if i need tips think about
what happens when you are at peak fear
you cannot stop [ __ ] you're gonna [ __ ]
that's that's true it can't physically
stop you literally
you just [ __ ] your brains out so those
people are geniuses i've never felt that
urge when i'm afraid no it's like
my body shuts it down so i can run you
get constipated you've never been truly
afraid i guess i haven't
challenged you to i measured how long it
took me to get through one roll of
toilet paper it took 14 days
did you bullet journal it i read
today my poop looked like this and this
is how much was left on the roll
15 days it's a long time i don't poop we
can move on oh is it
is it because oh because you have your
own bathroom that's why it took so long
because
because i don't poop it was just for
number one thank you for that yeah
because we all we all have our own
bathrooms that's true cause girls use
toilet paper more the guys do no
we don't because i wasn't gonna say
anything oh
they like bunch it all up they're like
what are you doing no because
okay so there's two bathrooms in our
place right and then i bought these two
little like piece of furniture thing to
put the the shelves of the toilet paper
in there
so then i filled both of them up at the
same time it's the upstairs one i
usually use and the downstairs one casey
usually uses
and he was like oh there's only two
rolls left but then he goes up and he
sees mine and my thing is like i only
use one roll
in the time that he used the whole thing
and i'm like what is happening
it's because you use it for peeing and
[ __ ] and he's using it for coming
and [ __ ]
that's cause i use the bidet and then he
has a bidet in his toilet too
but he doesn't use it oh he doesn't use
it
does he have allergies because i use
toilet paper a lot from my allergies
see he's using it for allergies come and
[ __ ] i cover that [ __ ] there's one of
these
everywhere in my house i actually
counted it yesterday because we were
literally talking about too much calm
and there's eleven twists so much around
my house
you do use a fuckton though if you don't
use the bidet
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you